in the United States the toy industry is
worth almost 20 billion dollars so we
think about shopping it only in
november/december it's a year-round
machine we're nearly rushing at 3 toys
from Lego Mattel and vex robotics these
are some of the biggest choice of the
year already and we really want to see
how they'll do during the holiday season
first up barbie this is probably gonna
be one of the biggest toys for the
holiday season since 1959 barbie is look
pretty much the same tall blonde and
beautiful but not exactly what every
little girl wants to grow up to look
like so Mattel decided to release 33 new
dolls now that they're out it boosted
their stock out of a long slump there's
something for everybody now and that's
gonna help Mattel his bottom line
come Christmas it should be a big big
sales hit from the telephone next up is
Lego and their newest addition to the
friends collection which are their toys
that are geared more for girls the
company wanted to reach the other 50% of
their potential user base and that's
what they did with the Friends
collection it's been wildly popular and
buyers love the amusement park that they
have out for this year one great thing
about the amusement park collection is
that it's not just all four girls and
covered in pink it's blue purple and
yellow and it's got some great little
details to it that buyers have loved
even the headlights on the roller
coaster light up and the ferris wheel is
all mobile too next up we have vexed
robotics they were named the toy
industry association educational toy of
the year that's a huge honor and they
want to be sure that that robot sells
this toy is expensive it's $300 but it's
worth it because it's all part of the
educational push to get kids to learn
stem younger and younger an extra plus
the robots really cute these are some of
the toys that we think will be hits for
the holiday season but you never know
it'll go flying off the shelves in
December
you